on trouve de tout presque au salon
international de l'agriculture ce qui en
fait sa popularité
plus de six cent mille visiteurs s'y
pressent en moyenne ces dernières années
une grande partie de ce succès vient des
animaux qui en font une ferme géante
chaque année depuis 1870 les épreuves du
concours général agricole permettent de
voir ce qui se fait de mieux en matière
d' espaces elles sont au nombre de huit
pour 340 sa race 13 cents éleveurs
sélectionneurs y participent
l'indre terre d'élevage sera représentée
cette année par 14 entre eux je pense
que c'est l'aboutissement de son travail
effectivement de pouvoir aller à paris
c'est pouvoir être reconnu alors on n'a
pas forcément besoin d'aller à paris
pour être connu puisque tous les
éléments en termes d'éleveurs je veux
dire appartement on est chez soi on fait
son travail comme il faut mais c'est
quand même une reconnaissance et après
vous avez une ouverture de porte et de
commerce que forcément on n'a pas en
restant chez nous cette année aucun
bovins de la race limousine ne fera le
déplacement à paris pour plusieurs
raisons là on a ce gros événement sur
châteauroux qui sera le concours
national où on va avoir quand même je
pense la plus grosse vitrine des
éleveurs de l'indre après il faut savoir
que paris ça a toujours un coup c'est un
coût financier effectivement maintenant
c'est moins aidés avant il y avait une
aide que te fait par le département
maintenant on est passé au niveau de la
région donc l'aide des mois
importante et ce à un terme aussi un
coût en terme de temps le temps manque
car la conjoncture économique actuelle
peu favorable à la production de viande
bovine oblige les éleveurs à agrandir
leurs troupeaux sans pouvoir embaucher
et améliorer la génétique est un travail
très prenant
c'est un concours sélectif dans le sang
sort effectivement la génétique ça se
travaille comme je disais tout à l'heure
on les vaches ne font qu'un veau dans
l'année donc pour arriver à faire de
mieux en mieux en sachant qu'on met la
barre de plus en plus haute a
aujourd'hui que ce soit en termes
d'engraissement que ce soit en termes de
reproducteurs donc effectivement je veux
dire le travail et de longue haleine
c'est pour ça que je vous dis quelqu'un
comme moi qui ai installé que depuis dix
ans à moins de sortir le produit
exceptionnel mais j'ai très peu de
chance je pense d'accéder à ce grade
blanc
la passion c'est ainsi que les quatre
éleveurs que nous avons rencontré
qualifient leur motivation pour les
concours ils découvriront leur
témoignage tout au long de la semaine